[Musique]
près de cent mille morts depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire en france plus de
5900 personnes actuellement en
réanimation les chiffres de l'épidémie
de coronavirus continue d'inquiéter et
l'afflux de malades sature toujours les
hôpitaux alors plus de 5900 personnes en
réanimation
le chiffre est aussi haut que l'année
dernière à la même période signe que la
crise malheureusement ne faiblit pas
depuis lundi la vaccination est ouverte
à tous les plus de 55 ans dont ka jarrar
des verres consommés à bras j'ai cru
malgré ça tous les jours
ça va bientôt tous les jours des
français sont prêts à faire la queue
pendant des heures pour une dose tu
attends quoi 2021 j'attends d'être
libéré de ce virus et qu'on puisse à
nouveau faire la fête ensemble danser
chanter s'embrasser ans qu'on aille vers
une société un petit peu plus humaniste
est la risée du monde entier
c'est quelqu'un qui avait laissé là par
les fabricants dont on peut rire ici
c'est vous n'annoncez je vais vous dire
pourquoi on peut rire je pense que vous
ne savez rien parce que vous ne
connaissez rien et que vous êtes là
juste effectivement pour faire de la
bonne animation et un peu de buzz
la vérité c'est qu'effectivement vous
lui avez très justement dit des gens
meurent on est parfaitement de rire et
attendait et aux gens qui meurent il ya
une chose qu'on doit c'est la vérité une
grande inspiration
et après tu vas écrire et de façon
continue ceci n'est pas un test
d'alcoolémie mais un dépistage contre
lacko vide à lyon des chercheurs
expérimentent cette pratique dont le
principe consiste à isoler les
particules expiré et ainsi détecter les
personnes infectées
cette machine permet d'obtenir le
résultat en moins de deux minutes
je n'ai pas vu la lumière et bientôt au
bout et comme dirait jean castex à
compter de 15 jours de nos jours il est
venu me tâte heures merci beaucoup
l'auront bon allez je rappelle nous
fêtons figurer avec lui qui dit qui dit
oui c'est pas grave rien n'est gravé qui
s'appelle we avec l'année vous
attendez-vous à venir
vous croyez quoi les galons de ces bons
ne vient pas c'est on va me revoir
non mais c'est bon là et au raja pas
demande de changer c'est tombé sous ses
doigts il passe son temps à hurler
ok je vais toujours mieux plus on va
toujours mieux vu ça fouette refermant
olalalala
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors sembler brigitte macro
pourquoi vous riez ses classes en plus
il lui arrive d'être chic avec une
touche rock à notre première dame
du coup elle est dans le thème l'un
christine non elle n'est pas dans le
thème la chic avec une touche rock
brigitte seth et cyril hanouna on était
sur le plateau ont pensé à vous avec un
grand v sa victoire
brigitte voulez vous embrassez vous dire
bon anniversaire plein de bonnes choses
j'ai fait livrer une table de ping pong
à l'elysée j'espère qu'il va arriver
bientôt
vous avez accepté aussi devenir pour
parler des propos de fait mal au coeur
quand vous à repasser nouvelle fois ce
soir
j'imagine pour votre plus grand plaisir
oui j'adore entendu ces mots
non franchement ça fait mal au coeur
c'est pas normal d'entendre ça à la télé
en 2021 et c'est profondément blessante
pour moi pour ma famille pour les gens
qui m'écoutent voilà c'est dur moi je
les critiquer sur son toit je trouverais
qu'elle avait quelques kilos de trop et
l'a mal pris mais ça a porté ses fruits
pas cela elle a perdu ses kilos et vous
même de vous même en le disant de face à
une caméra à la télévision vous rendez
compte que c'est l'année où jamais il
fallait quelque chose
autant voilà votre première réaction
elles étaient elles étaient faye avait
de l'humour quasiment pas ce que vous
confiez hésité entre offrir à fabien
lecoeuvre un poster ou un miroir mais en
vrai vous avez pas tellement envie d'en
rire
non j'en ai pas pleurer mais gens ça m'a
vraiment fait très mal au coeur parce
que parce que je pense que ça fait du
mal aussi haut enfin il ya des gens de
15 ans qui ont envie de se lancer dans
la musique et qui vont voir ça et en
fait ça c'est au delà de ces propos à
lui c'est quelque chose qui est qui se
passe sous le temps dans cette société
et dans ce milieu j'ai bastia un jour
note puisque on prendra notre métier
bah si je pense ça parce que c'est le
nouveau métier à tout le monde c'est le
métier pendant son v à dire genre à ses
copains est tout à fait c'est quoi tes
parents ils font quoi dans la vie
bah moi ont pas vraiment maman ils sont
influencés incroyable quand même non il
influe c'est un truc de fou
[Musique]
on a gagné et tu seras ce que ces
influenceurs ont pas beaucoup et c'est
là mon fils est déjà influencé
qui sait non mais franchement c'est un
métier qui en vogue les jeunes
maintenant ils préfèrent tous être
influenceurs que ouais que de venir le
médecin ou non mais c'est vrai c'est une
chance du japon au pérou les papilles
des lofteurs seront agités celle
inquiète au japon est un pion au pérou
je vous raconte pas la vue en afrique
je comprends pas ces nains pied japon et
un pied au pérou vous voyez la venue à
l'afrique
je vois deux boules et à côté je vois la
couille fraîchement découper du matin
[ __ ] que c'est beau ça ça c'était cqp
de boutons [ __ ] on apprenait aussi fin
mars et ça vous aimez aussi cet élément
de langage
apolline qu'il y avait eu rapprochement
actif en trois mois ordinaire du jour je
crois qu'ils ont fait l'amour mais non
we know me louis alors on souhaite ou
pas en ce sens one one est bien enceinte
a priori mon corps réagit tout seul et
j'ai envie de vomir mais c'est même pas
à 100 c'est psychologique à ce moment là
vraiment
[Musique]
pourquoi moi le mot testicules résonne
dans ma tête et là y'a un court circuit
je ne peux pas manger des festives que
je n'ai pas envie de manger des
testicules jamais d'autant que c'est pas
facile parce que les pandas bah ouais
c'est des gros animaux avec beaucoup de
poils donc pour que les positions soient
bonnes en fait si c'est quand même
quelqu'un je le dire en public parce que
c'est pas facile mais quand je me suis
lancé je n'arrivais plus